[Music]
can you believe I won have you been able
to process that you know I wasn't
supposed to win I'm completely shocked
and I have no idea yeah
I don't know how don't know how to react
it's totally surreal well I think it was
a shock it was a shock for Julie for
sure
well happy without Ross is gonna take it
home what do you think it was that
sealed the deal for you I think because
it what's weird was even Julie was like
I can't believe you took Ross that was
such a bad choice my son when my husband
were both like why did you do that
here's the deal I wouldn't have been
where I was if I hadn't been playing
with Ross Ross saved me time after time
my alliance with Ross was the only real
like true like we had each other's back
the whole time and you have to trust
somebody in the house right
so I trusted him and he trusted me so
not taking him to me wasn't part of my
spirit I was yes I'm a big brother fan
and I know in the big brother land that
was the worst move but in my heart and
in my soul and being a mother and
wanting to show like no if you have a
good friend regardless of what the
outcome is you take your friends this
money is just for you what are you gonna
do with it well I promised my son if I
won that he would get a warped wall from
American Ninja Warrior and he said if
you win and I said sure if I win
Celebrity Big Brother you can have a
warped wall and now I'm gonna have to
get him a warped wall cuz so I was like
there's no way I'll ever do that and now
I have to do it okay that's a pretty big
investment I mean it's a ridiculous
investment and I'm embarrassed
today it but it's the only thing I was
like I said oh yeah if I win you can
have it because I never was supposed to
win I went I didn't even plan the
dog-walker for past the first two weeks
so I was like I'm only gonna be there
for like two weeks and I'm gonna fine
it'll be great and I'll move on yeah it
was really funny you'll have to go back
and watch this but there's a montage of
you in the diary room telling your
husband to go like can somebody text my
husband to do this so stop it that is so
funny that is so funny are you gonna go
back and watch this I should like social
media at me watching it that my son
keeps telling me there's amazing clips
of me being like now meow meow meow and
then he's like day I was like he goes
he's like it's so funny he goes whenever
anyone talks about you they cut to you
being like ridiculous and I'm like
uh-uh editors like kept markup anytime
you were just making a strange sound
and we're like plug it in plug it in
plug it in I can't wait to watch it I'm
hoping all I cared about was not
embarrassing Zev with my son so I hope I
he says I didn't but will fame know you
were so much fun to watch you and Ross
were so much fun to watch together who
is your friend for life out of this game
rod Roth and Ari for sure I mean like
everybody in the house ara but like I
had a really special bond with Rozlyn
Ari
[Music]